airports
and golf shoes
that's right everyone's been interested
in
airports and golf shoes
the queen is still making your way
around the uk
and donald trump made his way back to
washington
we don't know why there's a lot of
speculation on why donald trump's in
washington it sounds like jared kushner
has a uh
he has he has an event
he has an america first nazi rally or
something
i don't i don't know i mean that's
that's what i have to
question
that's where i go with it
and i'm serious it's an america first
thing i'm not i'm not [ __ ] you it's
it's a fascist thing
i mean
jared kushner
is now a full-on fascist they're not
semi-fascist
by the way
the right wing
it's still
so pissed off
about joe biden
calling trump supporters semi-fascist
you bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
what are you ty why are you so mad that
joe biden called you semi-fascist
like he's being nice
he's being nice to you
i won't be not i don't give a [ __ ] i
won't be nice
he's being nice to you when he calls you
a semi-fascist
he's being
nice to you
you're a [ __ ] nazi if you still
support these treasonous bastards
this morning
trump
files his rebuttal his motion
and says you proof
prove that they're classified
net
and oh by the way
they're mine they're not yours they're
not yours
it's not your [ __ ] it's our [ __ ] it's
the government [ __ ]
and the burden of proof is on you dummy
you're the one who said you waved your
big mac stained hands over these
documents and declassified them of
course everyone's still saying this [ __ ]
as if this is the way that it actually
is and as if
even though this information is
declassified that makes it better
why why the [ __ ] do you think it makes
it better
so we have that to deal with today
we have a special guest with us today
a political strategist and political
commentator
sherry jacobus is going to join us at
the bottom of the hour
excited averager i saw a tweet
that she sent out i think was actually a
reply
where she's talking about
what their plan is
for trump to take over and i'm talking
about the maga
the maga republicans the actual fascist
that's what they are they're fascist
they're not semi semi-fascist
there there are some republicans that
are semi-fascist
there are
but they generally see the danger of
trump i mean bill barr for example bill
barr is a semi-fascist
at this point you know
and comparatively comparatively
billbar is like
he did what with classified documents
again trump trump has two airport videos
this weekend two of them
two airplane airport videos
one was from yesterday
from last night he lands in dulles
in dc
it's an international airport everyone's
like oh [ __ ] is he going to russia
is he getting on a plane to saudi arabia
i mean you know it's an international
airport so generally speaking you're
going to an international airport you
flying
overseas to another country
presumably but he flew to
dc
on a little on a little private jet
because he he can't afford his big one
anymore
he can't if he can't afford
his compensation point you know he's got
to compensate
and i think that maybe maybe that's why
he didn't want anyone know he was coming
to dc because he wouldn't be flying in
on his compensation jet
compensating for you know
you know the stormy daniels story
the little shroom
but he flew on a little bitty private
jet
it was his it was marked his
there was a video out there on the
internet there was pictures out there on
the internet
it was verified that it was yes it was
yesterday
and he gets off the plane
and what appears to be golf attire like
he just came off
the golf course which is not a big
surprise
i mean to think that this guy
you know probably
lays around in golf clothes
i mean
it's all he does he didn't work he
didn't do anything of interest his
[ __ ] golf
i mean i'm not saying golf is bad
golf sucks but
we'll get into the golf thing but he had
golf shoes on he didn't even have time
to change his shoes which led some
people to believe
that this was not planned
that it was all of a sudden that he had
to hop on this little bitty tiny private
jet
and head to dc because he was in new
jersey a lot of people thought he was at
mar-a-lago he wasn't he hadn't been at
mar-a-lago and the reason why is because
he can't live down there full-time
because they'll kick him out because the
original agreement he made
he has to go away for a while and then
come back
some are surmising maybe that's the
reason why he's headed to dc
maybe there's documents
and some of his properties around dc and
virginia
so he would go there it seemed as if it
seemed as if
because he had his golf shoes on and he
was
escorted on the plane so quickly that he
couldn't change his clothes or his golf
shoes
maybe just maybe it was a medical
emergency it didn't appear to me to be a
medical emergency to be quite honest
with you i mean i think if they would
have had a medical emergency they would
had him on the off the plane much
quicker
into the car much quicker it would have
been much quicker to
get away from the airport too
if he was going to walter reed
now again that was some of the first
speculation
there's other video out there of him
heading to the airport to go to dc in
new jersey
but there's this america first nazi
rally that jared kushner is going to be
the host of today
and what better
what better person than have the orange
mussolini jesus himself to appear
at the america first fascist rally
i mean makes sense
kind of makes sense the other thing that
might make sense is maybe just maybe
because we know there's a grand jury
around not just january 6 but the the
grand jury seems to be probing
specifically
specifically
the save america pact and the
legal defense fund which is all [ __ ]
it's all [ __ ] the january 6 select
committee smash that up with a hammer
like oh you're claiming to collect money
for your legal defense where that money
oh there is no legal defense fund hmm
funny you mean it's a fraud hmm
interesting so it seems like there's a
grand jury that has been convened
because tucker carlson freaked out he
was freaking out on his show on fox news
oh there's 50 trump supporters that are
getting raided they weren't raided
they were issued subpoenas
not raided i mean
i mean i guess if someone comes to your
house and hands you a piece of paper and
serves you
republicans now think that means rated
oh my god well i mean when a white
person
you know gets handed to speed now that's
rated
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
when you when you break the law when you
commit crimes or aid in a bed or
or cooperate and conspire with people
who break the law
you generally you generally are
witness target of interest
to the department of justice in a
criminal probe
with said crime
how is this even [ __ ] surprising i
don't know why anyone would be in a room
close to this son of a [ __ ]
i have no idea why
they would even be in a room close to
this [ __ ]
because you know he's saying all types
of crazy stuff hell he's been saying it
since 2020 after he knew he lost
more news maggie haberman
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] listen if you held
on to information that the american
people
should have had
to prevent an event
like january 6
and you held it for profit for a book
your piece of
[ __ ] you're you're not a journalist
you're a profiteer
that's that's what you are you might as
well just stop calling yourself a
journalist and acting like a journalist
and really
the the
the journalist outlet that you work for
should say as much too
because apparently maggie haberman not
only heard donald trump but had witness
witnesses of aids
even that even the [ __ ] guy that
brought him his diet coke
the guy who brought him the [ __ ] diet
coke the guy who who had to you know
pour his diet coke in a glass over a
certain amount of ice cubes
you know
have a golden tray i'm sure
i'm sure he had to observe it with a
couple package of ketchup i don't know
he eats ketchup on steak maybe he eats
ketchup with diet coke i don't know
but he had to come in the oval office
and hand him his diet coke when trump
pushed the diet coke button the diet
coke button guy the delivery guy for the
diet coke button
he was telling that guy
he was telling him hey
should i stay or should i go
you